what's the deal with everything peanuts
peanuts
Outsider Misfit criminal convict movie
star Family Man comedy Legend Joey Diaz
has been called every name in the book
and then some now for the first time he
shares the story of his unlikely rise to
Fame in his own words with no punches
pulled
Joey Diaz wasn't always a star but he
was always a comedian it just took him a
while to figure it out to be fair he was
pretty busy when he was young helping
his mother in her bar holding a gun for
the first time at the age of six and
later dealing drugs and serving time
tremendous is the story of Diaz's life
from grueling childhood and misbent
youth to finding his true calling in
comedy immigrants fans of celebrity
tales and comedy enthusiasts alike will
all be enthralled by this incredibly
true foul-mouthed and funny Memoir it's
not a story for the faint of heart or
for proves to have never spent a week
sleeping in a piece of playground
equipment from finding his mom's body to
high-state Crime addiction and
depression there are plenty of Dark
episodes in this Saga Dia shares it all
with brutal honesty and humor in the
same voice he'd use talking to you from
the stage or in a bar he also shares the
story of his improbable rise to the top
and the bumpy road that led him there
that was the description for Uncle
Joey's brand new book titled tremendous
the life of a comedy Savage every
[__] day I write a paragraph or two I
write ideas for the upcoming chapters
I've got it outlined if there was any
one comedian who had a life story worth
sharing in a book I think we can all
agree it's Joey Coco Diaz his journey to
the top of the comedy game is filled
with unbelievable twists and turns from
a life of guns and drugs to hosting a
podcast and meeting Joe Rogan Joey Diaz
has a mind-blowing story for any
situation and we never get tired of
hearing them it's also no secret that us
comedy fans dearly missed the old church
of what's Happening Now podcast Uncle
Joey's joint is definitely a solid show
and Joey has his moments but still we
can all agree it's a far cry from The
Glory Days of the church with the flying
Julie Saya and their 500 milligram stars
of death but that's exactly why we
should be so excited for this new book
especially if Uncle Joey plans to record
the audio version in his own voice
listening to Joey Diaz himself tell his
complete life story from growing up in
New Jersey to becoming a comedy staple
is almost gonna feel like taking a time
machine back to the Glory Days of the
church there's buzzer underwear bro they
put these underwear when the urine would
hit him a buzzer would go off oh my God
I'm not joking look him up online this
ain't no joke bro so I went to my
grandparents my mother didn't tell him
that I had these right I'm really hoping
these are real singing not just like a
torture device your parents
by themselves this doctor gave him to us
dude this dude was a bunch of Google
this dude was a Bonafide doctor so we
went there I got the electric pants on
dude you know
wait wait what'd you like Google I'm
getting my rest probably uh you know
buzzer underwear for urinators oh Google
buzzer underwear for urinators
um and uh so then but they didn't tell
my grandfather right
so he [__] had a small house bro
little bitty house
so my [__] crotch is just but like he
he wakes up middle of the night dude
you're on fire I'm not on fire but I'm
buzzing hard bro cause I'd had apple
juice man and I pissed big on apple
juice dude I [__] spray out on the AJ
so I'm in there just buzzing dude I
didn't know and he came in
yeah hit me apparently
it's also just nice to see more
comedians writing books in general I
really enjoy Tom segura's collection of
essays he put out in book form almost a
year ago and I have just as high of
hopes for tremendous you can pre-order
Joey's book right now on Amazon or wait
till May 2nd when it comes out in stores
and honestly I'm really excited to
finally get to read this thing and to
report my thoughts back to you guys
right here on the joke World comedy news
update I'm still writing the book guy
listen the movie came out nothing has
happened for me I have not heard from my
theatrical ages I don't give a [__] I'm
not mad or anything this is giving me a
chance to work on this book so I talked
to her we talk an hour and a half
on the phone four times a week this book
is moving a lot [__] fast than I
anticipated you know I would go on these
[__] ear beatings and ever since I'm
not high all the time anymore now when I
do the I look at the main [__]
diagram whatever the thing we did and
then I simplify it I rewrite it and I
tell her on the phone and we just go
back and forth so the process has been
great I'm really happy to do this uh my
niece is going through some pictures so
she's getting all the pictures together
for the book and all that so it's coming
together great and I got to be honest
with you this thing was eating away at
me for seven [__] years I couldn't
get this done it's amazing when people
know what the [__] they're doing you
know what I'm saying like you next time
your car breaks and you're like I'll do
it I go on YouTube that's great that's
great but when you call me so weird
noise don't come [__] crying to me
last week two very popular podcasts
announced new plans for live shows
starting off with Bill Burr and the
Monday Morning podcast Bill himself
announced the plans for the live show on
Instagram with the caption reading quote
announcing the Monday Morning podcast
live tickets will be available for all
Monday Morning podcast has listeners to
take part in the digital experience no
matter where in the world you call home
April 23rd we also had taste buds
announcing the first ever live battle
will take place on May 10th at 9pm
Eastern both of these live shows will be
hosted on momenthouse.com guest spots
from last week your mom's house had on
the ru garbage boys two bears one cave
was Tom and Big Jay oakerson kill Tony
this week was also with our garbage boys
plus Giannis Papas Anthony Jeselnik was
on the Heartland Highway Esther povitzky
was the guest in savi's World Ryan
sickler was on are you garbage as well
as whiskey Ginger and we might be drunk
head on Jim Norton could we deal with
hecklers like if a guy heckles you it's
right there you deal with it it's
addressed yes you he knows you know what
he said they all know it's almost like
you have the judge and the jury in the
same room yes but you don't have that
online because you know but that thing
you said it's too diluted but in a club
it's you suck and then you Hammer them
yeah oh it's so satisfying it's
literally a town hall meeting where you
get Applause after every Interruption
yeah it's [__] great yeah because
you're always gonna win oh yeah if you
don't win you can yeah I mean you have a
microphone yeah you should I've gone
sometimes you go too hard yeah you lose
yeah hey you [__] and they're like whoa
easy yeah oh it's a kid walking through
to the bathroom
but then you can kind of [__] on
yourself for going too hard there's
still ways to save it that's true and uh
you're always gonna you're always gonna
come off better than them yeah yeah I
mean early on I definitely lost yes oh
early on I remember some of those where
you're like oh I I saw a legendary one
it wasn't me but I was at a show and a
comic was on stage doing a fat joke and
a guy in the front row was like crazy
obese like huge and he goes hey enough
with the fat stuff and he goes sir relax
you're gonna die in a year anyway and he
the whole crowd turned on the guy stood
up it got ugly and uh I was like all
right noted don't do that yeah hopefully
he was right though yeah you guys stood
up and he was like oh yeah he's reading
the obituaries for the next 12 months I
was crying this past weekend with the
Yvonne talked with Stavros stavi was
also on the Tim Dillon show The Joe
Rogan Experience had on Sam Talent
godfreed was on tigerbelly Jason Ellis
was on the Honeydew Chrissy chaos did
not have a guest Sal vulcano was on the
blocks podcast and Drew Lynch was a
guest on you know what dude as far as
new stand-up specials go They're either
premiering soon or out right now Stavros
halcus uploaded a brand new crowd work
special on his YouTube know last
Wednesday it's 30 minutes long and is
already well past 600 000 views there's
no issue it's going good for YouTube
right no way no right yeah
you've got an interesting energy about
you some
something's off I can't tell what it is
you're wound a little tight
[Laughter]
need a massage or something I don't know
are you dealing with any stress is
something at work maybe
you're there all the time what do you do
firemen oh okay oh yeah something's
[__] up
[Laughter]
you farming too are you guys you are
okay nice did you ever do the little is
that thing real where everybody slides
on the little thing
the pole you guys got a pole
is that that much faster than stairs
it feels like it's just more for Panache
you know
Kyle Kinane shocks and struts is also
out right now on YouTube and two
specials coming out relatively soon John
Mulaney baby Jay will be on Netflix
April 24th and Jimmy Yang has a new
special coming to Amazon on May 2nd also
if anyone's curious as to why I'm
sitting in front of this joke World flag
and I'm not in our normal Studio it's
because I'm currently in Austin Texas
attending moon tower Comedy Festival as
well as checking out the already
thriving comedy scene here in Austin
that we've all heard so much about I'll
be reporting everything that happens
here this week back to you all very soon
so if you're interested in the Austin
scene the comedy Mothership kill Tony or
just enjoy clicking buttons subscribe to
joke world right now and you won't miss
a thing
foreign
[Music]